hi guys it's me
Tiffany tumbles transgender YouTube
sensation welcome to my world
every week I upload new beauty and
makeup tutorials come get ready with me
so I'm gonna go with the color snowflake
from my one Arlo's palette using a flock
325 - smoke it Oh
what I just kind of shudder it looks
bomb it's a major I'm reviving it I'm
obsessed
it's literally snatched - love love love
yeah okay
I'm not living for it oh my god I think
I glued my eye shot [ __ ] but I'm not
just a pretty face I also share plenty
of opinions about controversial social
and political issues even though I'm
trans I refuse to be a victim because I
prefer to take control of my own life
which is why I support our president
Donald J from make tracks gay again
buying
[Music]
hi I'm Jackie Jackson host of the
Freedom report we're I'm sorry why
doesn't my studio look like a Japanese
drag queen redecorated an Italian
bordello it's it's hard to move past it
anyway tonight my guests are to
transgender youtubers from opposite ends
of the political spectrum but I've
brought them here together to engage in
a rational free thinking debate about a
timeless question our traps gay my first
guest is Adria Finley host of the
popular youtube series intersectional AF
Clarence hey YouTube it's you girl
Adriana have you ever considered that
transphobia is racist
okay my other guest is returning to the
show it's Tiffany chuckles now Tiffany
you've had a major change of heart since
the last time you were on this program
isn't that right that's right Jackie
it's pretty embarrassing but I used to
be a non-binary sjw you poor thing could
you say a little bit about how you came
to take the red pill well I posted a
couple tweets about how there are only
two genders and how I was tired of
trendy teens who don't experience
dysphoria calling themselves trans and
next thing I know everyone's calling me
a turf and a traitor so I said you know
what I'm out I'm not gonna put up with
this culture of silencing and shame I
think it's just so brave of you yeah Wow
so brave of you to come on talk shows to
discuss how silenced you are shut up
Adriana I had just come out as trans and
I was putting myself out there online
and then like that the trans community
dropped me like a piece of trash and I
had no support nothing
I was absolutely alone do you have any
idea what that felt like your leftist
allies are not your friends adrià one
wrong move and you're dead to them those
are not friends well you have real
friends now Tiffany I think you're gonna
fit right in with this new group of
dangerous intellectuals who are finally
taking a stand against the authoritarian
left and speaking out against
politically correct dogma why don't we
go ahead and roll a clip of one of
Tiffany's newest videos so I'm gonna go
in with a highlighter pop it on my
cheeks
pop it on my brow till I'm literally
blinding I am glowing hmm she's doing
alright but I'm not living for it you
know what else I'm not living for the
Muslims
Tiffany you are so funny I'm sorry are
we just gonna ignore the blatant racism
I was that racist Muslim is a religion
not a race yeah adrià Muslim is a
religion not a race well in this country
Islam and race are inextricably tied
together
you can't just well you both know
exactly what I'm talking about let's try
to get back on track here so adrià craps
are they gay look there's so many things
wrong with the question that the only
way to answer is to deconstruct it first
of all what are traps are they trans
women because if you're calling trans
women traps then you're directly playing
into the lie that trans women are
tricking or trapping men a lie that
reinforces the mentality that causes men
to murder us well I don't think trout
does necessarily a trans woman what
about anime okay so the word trap was
invented by english-speaking anime fans
the japanese word is otokonoko which
just means a male crossdresser there's
no implication of tricking men but the
word trap is sometimes used in English
as a slur against trans women so when
you tell us that's not what it means
you're gaslighting the [ __ ] out of us
because we've all heard it used as a
slur adrià you don't get to speak for
all trans women we're not all offended
all the time I actually happen to
identify as a trap
yeah Adria she identifies as a trap well
she's in the second place and Tiffany
that's pretty reckless doesn't it bother
you at all that if some guy murders you
his defense is gonna be well she was a
trap I was tricked and you'll have
contributed to that way of thinking what
do you care Adria no one's gonna be
trapped by you anyway Oh spicy my [ __ ]
did you just say I said no shade but you
don't really look like a woman Jackie
are you going to allow your guest to
talk to me like this well Tiffany you
could stand to be a little nicer look
dragging [ __ ] is what I do
fax over feels hunty Wow Adrian don't
you think she has a bit of a point look
if you want to be taken seriously you
could put a little more effort in I mean
what is this a men's shirt how are you
gonna attract men with that I'm not
trying to attract men I'm a lesbian
I'm sorry maybe this is a stupid
question but how can you be
trans woman and a lesbian well I'm a
woman and I like women I don't know
about that sounds debatable I'm sorry I
didn't realize when I agreed to do this
show that I was signing up for the
transphobia special transphobia
well Adria I think that's very unfair I
mean I've invited two trans women to be
on my program and all how do you know
that one of my best friends happens to
be a gay man and what could be
transphobic about that see Adria you're
the reason why everyone hates trans
people you're obnoxious and offended by
everything and everyone feels like they
have to try not a comes around you Thank
You Tiffany see you're one of the good
ones
you're a good Tran is this what you want
to do with your life Tiffany be the
lapdog of people like this no I want to
actually work toward the acceptance of
trans people by being patient in
agreeable and by looking the part
and not by screeching transphobia at
everyone who doesn't meet your
impossible standard of woek nests and
you're gonna do that by identifying as a
trap huh just keep reinforcing and
excusing bigotry until it magically goes
away well does it occur to you Tiffany
that you're not gaining acceptance for
anyone but yourself
and the only reason you're accepted is
that you don't challenge the status quo
I'm sorry I need to interrupt this
exchange of ideas because I feel like
we're just getting hung up on
terminology look Adria if you don't like
the word trap we just won't use the word
trap the real question is is it gay to
be attracted to trans women it is if
you're a woman no I mean for men like
Tiffany duty the straight man or gay man
well all the men I've dated only date
women but if they're attracted to me I
mean it's not the straightest thing is
it why not
you look like a woman and I know that
you know that gay men are not attracted
to these tits
well I am serving up fishy realness so
granted well doesn't she have a point
though Adria I mean sure she looks like
a woman but she does have XY chromosomes
when was the last time you were
attracted to a person's chromosomes the
thoughtful sexuality works we're
attracted to a person's perceptible
feature is not molecular biology okay
sure but I mean a lot of trans women
still have their penis and you got to
admit that seems kind of gay Jackie you
really have no clue what you're doing do
you we live in a world where there's no
shortage of men who want to date trans
women but there's an intense stigma on
dating
women and it's actually dangerous
because what happens is if a man's
friends find out that the woman he's
dating his trans he may try to preserve
as toxic masculine dignity by lashing
out violently against the trans woman
he's dating and this happens again and
again and every time you suggest that
dating a trans woman is gay you're
adding to that stigma and you're making
the world a more dangerous and violent
place for trans women all right I'm not
trying to use violent words or whatever
I just don't understand who a person
who's attracted to women could be
attracted to a person with a penis well
if you want to know I'll tell you I am a
lesbian I'm only attracted to women
including trans women and what I'm
attracted to a trans woman I perceive
her as a woman and if she has a penis I
perceive it not in isolation but as a
part of her female body so I perceive it
not as a male penis but as a girl dick
I'm sorry what
what does girl dick the feminine penis
oh no oh come on this is nonsense how
could a penis possibly be feminine well
it's feminine because it's on a woman
but also because hormones actually
change the anatomy and functionality of
the penis shut up adrià just shut hobby
really how is it different well I'm glad
you asked more needs to be said about
the feminine penis why is no one talking
about the feminine penis kill me now
also to start with it doesn't get us
hard
it doesn't really ejaculate and it has a
different mouthfeel can we please talk
about the mouthfeel why has no one
talking about the mouthfeel I don't
think that's necessary I'm just trying
to wrap my head around this you are
attracted to women with dicks but not to
men that's correct
I don't like man take its course and
rough and irritating and it comes
everywhere not like girl tech girl dick
is everything soft and smooth is that
Star Wars that do you also build
computers for a living I mean guilty I
also enjoy wearing knee socks
and let me guess your girlfriend is a
communist cat girl my sweet love wait
you're dating my crazy aunt Eva cat well
we're on the same poly fuel I don't know
what that means
and I'm not like prejudiced or anything
but I'm just not sold on this idea of
trans lesbianism like if you're a born
male and you're attracted to women how
is it not just heterosexuality well my
girlfriend is also trans so if you
follow your logic to its conclusion okay
so you're a woman who was born a man and
you like women but you're dating a woman
who has a penis are the female penis
that used to be a male penis so you're a
rare woman with it but you're not a man
and your tract has a penis why that used
to be a man you're dating a female who
has a penis
so that means you are gay but you're gay
in the opposite way how's the kind of
gay that you like go over it with you
again after the show if you need some
extra time to figure it out what am i
constantly surrounded by homosexual
adrià just stop talking look I don't
care what you're doing private but I'm
sorry to break it to you the world is
not ready to hear about trans lesbianism
what trans people need right now is
people like you to keep a low profile
and people like me to be our
representatives because I act like a
normal woman and I date normal men and I
don't have a catgirl girlfriend with a
girl dick ah also I look [ __ ]
gorgeous I'm sorry but that matters
well you look just fine but let's not
get arrogant sweetheart you're not
Blaire white well I haven't saved the
money to have work done so there's not a
fair comparison well were you having
done I'm gonna lower my hairline shave
some bone off my jaw reshape my brow get
some lip injections maybe Botox my
forehead oh and I'm gonna fix my nose
obviously what's wrong with your nose
it's kind of big and mannish well my
nose looks kind of like that are you
saying I look mannish are you saying I
look ugly what are you trying to say
Tiffany why are you doing this to me why
are you doing this to women I'm not
doing anything to women what what look
we can't all become hairless sex dolls
that's a terrible thing to say to a Tran
and she has worked really hard to be
seen as female and you just don't shut
the hell up Adria don't get offended for
me don't condescend to me I'm not a
victim okay so I'm not as young as I
used to be but my fiancee still thinks
I'm beautiful I need to not be around a
long time
all right let's let's forget about it
I'm I'm fine
Tiffany are you fine I am fine to be
clear are not fine with any of this look
why don't we just edit this whole thing
out let's shoot the closer and we'll fix
it in post well we may never know
whether traps are doing but the
important thing is that we talked about
me
I'm Jackie Jackson for the freaking pool
with a debate never starts your mascara
is running get out of my studio but both
of you go we're done hi Nick y'all
finished well it was a [ __ ] show no
Adrienne was fine she was cringes [ __ ]
the whole time let's have her back
Tiffany was the problem she had kind of
earring off message and she got
emotional
ya don't have a her back get Blair next
time and the week after
can we get Kanye West we can't get Kanye
get Candace Owens Oh what have you done
to my studio
hey Adria look I'm sorry I was rude to
you back there okay it's just that I've
been working so hard to win acceptance
for transpeople
to show her whenever normal or just like
them enter when you show up looking like
that and acting like that it's it's just
hard for me to watch all my hard work
being done you know like you can't be
talking about this feminine penis in
front of sis people Tiffany you need to
get far away from me right now for your
own physical sea oh my god you crazy
freak
[Music]
I hate a dream
she looks like a man-beast society needs
to stop enabling these ridiculous
delusions ah this hon people are gonna
see this they're gonna think this is
what trans people are should not be
representing artists they're nothing
like me
I'm nothing like that ain't you relax
[Music]
but Atreus [ __ ] everything alright
what are they saying
[Music]
okay so your but at least I know them I
may have a mental illness I'm a
self-aware about it not dutiful I'm not
like Adria I don't think it's it's fine
this is it's gotta be fun
I'm gonna have the work done I can fix
this it's my fault for not worrying
harder that you can't just expect
society to I'm not a victim I am in
control of my life I wish for anything
with this
[Music]
[Applause]
hi guys it's me Tiffany tall's welcome
[Music]